[Applaus] ach ja warum werden sie sich
jetzt fragen muss das hier eigentlich
wieder ein Österreicher moderieren naja weil
wir das gut können also nicht das Moderieren
aber aber das rechte weil wir für uns sind
die Rechten schon lange ganz normal wir in
Österreich sind ihnen auf der Reise in die
Vergangenheit mindestens 20 Jahre voraus ich
weiß ich weiß ich weiß der erste rechtsextreme
Landrat der tut noch weh aber glauben Sie mir
wenn in 20 Jahren Außenminister Björn höcke
im Kabinett an die scheuer mit dem Kreisen
Wladimir Putin auf dem Oktoberfest Walter
Tanz dann werden uns ganz normal vorkommen
vielleicht kommt es aber anders und scheuer
ist der Außenminister der Bundeskanzler aus
Versehen weil der Scheuer die eigene Leute
mal wieder mit der AFD verwechselt hat
also reden sie sich nicht auf es bringt ja
nichts nicht erinnern Sie sich zum Beispiel
an das Jahr 2000 Aufregung in Europa ja
kein das FPÖ tritt in die österreichische
Regierung ein Tag gab es Sanktionen also man
ist mit den Vertretern der schwarz-blauen
Regierung nach dem diplomatischen Abendessen
nichts mehr trinken gegangen das war Hort
man kann den Österreicher doch nicht alleine
saufen lassen das ist doch unmenschlich noch
schlimmer ungemütlich deshalb auch ein Jahr später
berlos gronig zum zweiten Mal Ministerpräsident in
Italien und nichts keine Reaktion niehen und
wie jetzt die Julia Melanzani Georgia Melone
Ministerpräsidentin geworden ist da hat
er sogar die kommissionspräsidentin von
der Leyen persönlich gratuliert natürlich nur
ihr als Frau nicht ihr als faschistin wird das
neue normalen und wir in Österreich wir kennen
das schon ja die nationale Normalität im schönen
Niederösterreich z.B haben wir eine schwarz blaue
rechtsrechte Koalition und das sagt jetzt die
Frau Landeshauptmann oder daher Landeshauptfrau
so genau weiß man das nicht sie repräsentiere
die normal denken die Mehrheit und wenn der
Vizekanzler von den Grünen das dann privat
ob sein verstehst du wirklich oder dann
weiß man nicht oder weiß ein Fremdwort ist
in Niederösterreich ist eigentlich alles so normal
dass einem braunen vor Augen wird denn dort dort
will man Deutsch als schulhofsprache durchsetzen
Deutsch in Niederösterreich da müssen wir erstmal
die ganze Schule ein semesterbildungsurlaub in
Hannover machen aber nicht nur das Wirtshäuser
die traditionelle Speisen wie Schweinsbraten und
schweineschnitzeln und schweinskrankenschwendern
anbieten sollen gefördert werden und wenn wir
noch so viele Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen haben
herzverfettungen Cholesterinwerte gehen durch
die Decke ist egal die Sau muss hinein in uns
damit wir sie später wieder rauslassen können
denn der FPÖ-Chef will nicht nur der nächste
Kanzler werden sondern Volkskanzler und
das Volkskanzler sagt er zu seinem Volk
folgt und so bauen wir dann
an der Festung Österreich
ja
die Festung Österreich da kommen dann nur
noch Ausländer hinein die in den Bergen
Urlaub machen oder die Ausländer die die
anderen Ausländern auf dem Bergen bewirten
damit dann alle im Ausland sehen was für ein
kulturell hochstehendes Land wir sind und
dann vielleicht verscherbelt die rechtsrechte
Regierung das ganze Land an Dritte Ausländer
Russen zum Beispiel aber so dass diesmal keiner
ein Video davon macht also wenn aufregen reden
genau
wo sie abonnieren können
das jetzt noch zwei weitere Videos gucken
können unsere Zuschauer sind ja sehr klug